we're going to do the use case text
classification
now i would challenge you to go back and
send us a note on the
notes below underneath the video and
request the data for the
shopping cart so you can plug that into
python code and do that on your own time
so you can
walk through it since we walked through
all the information on it but we're
going to do a python code
doing text classification very popular
for doing the naive bayes
so we're going to use our new tool to
perform a text classification of news
headlines and classified news into
different topics for a news website
as you can see here we have a nice image
of the google news
and then related on the right subgroups
i'm not sure where they actually pulled
the actual data we're going to use from
it's one of the
standard sets but certainly this can be
used on any of our news headlines in
classification so
let's see how it can be done using the
naive bayes classifier
now we're at my favorite part we're
actually going to write some python
script
roll up our sleeves and we're going to
start by doing our imports
these are very basic imports including
our news group and we'll take a quick
glance at the target names
then we're going to go ahead and start
training our data set and putting it
together
we'll put together a nice graph because
it's always good to have a graph to show
what's going on
and once we've traded it and we've shown
you a graph of what's going on
then we're going to explore how to use
it and see what that looks like
now i'm going to open up my favorite
editor or inline editor for python you
don't have to use this you can use
whatever your editor that you
like whatever interface ide you want
this just happens to be the anaconda
jupiter notebook
and i'm going to paste that first piece
of code in here so we can walk through
it
let's make it a little bigger on the
screen so you have a nice view of what's
going on
and we're using python 3 in this case
3.5
so this would work in any of your 3x if
you have it set up correctly should also
work in a lot of the 2x
you just have to make sure all of the
versions of the modules match your
python version
and in here you'll notice the first line
is your percentage
matte plot library in line now three of
these lines of code are all about
plotting the graph this one lets
the notebook notes as an inline setup
that we want the graphs to show up
on this page without it in a notebook
like this which is an
explorer interface it won't show up now
a lot of ides don't require that
a lot of them like on if i'm working on
one of my other setups
it just has a pop-up and the graph pops
up on there so you have
that set up also but for this we want
the matplot library in line
and then we're going to import numpy as
np
that's number python which has a lot of
different formulas in it
that we use for both of our sklearn
module
and we also use it for any of the upper
math functions in python and it's very
common to see that as np
numpy as np the next two lines are all
about
our graphing remember i said three of
these were about graphing well we need
our matplot library dot pi plot
as plt and you'll see that plt is a very
common setup as
is the sns and just like the np and
we're going to import
seaborn as sns and we're going to do the
sns.set
now seaborn sits on top of pie plot
and it just makes a really nice heat map
it's really good for heat maps and if
you're not familiar with heat maps that
just means we give it a color scale
the term comes from the brighter red it
is the hotter it is
in some form of data and you can set it
to whatever you want
and we'll see that later on so those
you'll see that those three lines of
code here are just importing the graph
function so we can graph it
and as a data science test you always
want to graph your data and have some
kind of visual
it's really hard just to shove numbers
in front of people and they look at it
and it doesn't mean anything
and then from the sklearn.datasets
we're going to import the fetch 20 news
groups very common one for analyzing
tokenizing words and setting them up and
exploring how the words work and how do
you categorize different things when
you're dealing with documents
and then we set our data equal to fetch
20 news groups so our data variable will
have the data in it
and we're going to go ahead and just
print the target names data.target names
and let's see what that looks like
and you'll see here we have alt atheism
comp graphics comp osms windows dot
miscellaneous
and it goes all the way down to talk
politics dot miscellaneous talk
religion dot miscellaneous these are the
categories they've already assigned
to this news group and it's called fetch
20 because you'll see there's i believe
there's 20 different topics in here or
20 different categories
as we scroll down now we've gone through
the 20 different categories and we're
going to go ahead
and start defining all the categories
and set up our data
so we're actually getting here going to
go ahead and get it get the data all set
up and take a look at our data
and let's move this over to our jupiter
notebook and let's see what this code
does
first we're going to set our categories
now if you noticed up here i could have
just as easily set this equal to
data.target underscore names because
it's the same thing
but we want to kind of spell it out for
you so you can see the different
categories
it kind of makes it more visual so you
can see what your data is looking like
in the background
once we've created the categories we're
going to open up a train
set so this training set of data is
going to go into fetch 20 news groups
and it's a subset in there
called train and categories equals
categories so we're pulling out those
categories that match
and then if you have a train set you
should also have the testing set we have
test equals fetch 20 news groups subset
equals test
and categories equals categories let's
go down one size so it all fits on my
screen
there we go and just so we can really
see what's going on let's see what
happens when we print out
one part of that data so it creates
train and under train it creates train
dot data
and we're just going to look at data
piece number five and let's go ahead and
run that and see what that looks like
and you can see when i print train dot
data number five under train
it prints out one of the articles this
is article number five you can go
through and read it on there
and we can also go in here and change
this to test which should look identical
because it's splitting the data up into
different groups
train and test and we'll see test number
five is a
different article but it's another
article in here and maybe you're curious
and you want to see
just how many articles are in here we
could do
length of train dot data
and if we run that you'll see that the
training data has
11 314 articles
so we're not going to go through all
those articles that's a lot of articles
but we can look at one of them just you
can see what kind of information is
coming out of it and what we're looking
at and we'll just look at number five
for today
and here we have it rewording the second
amendment ids vtt
line 58 lines 58 in article
uh et cetera and you can scroll all the
way down and see all the different parts
to there
now we've looked at it and that's pretty
complicated when you look at one of
these articles to try to figure out how
do you
weight this if you look down here we
have different words and maybe the word
from
well from is probably in all the
articles so it's not going to have a lot
of
meaning as far as trying to figure out
whether this article fits one of the
categories or not
so trying to figure out which category
it fits in based on these words is where
the challenge comes in
now that we've viewed our data we're
going to dive in and do the actual
predictions this is the actual naive
bayes
and we're going to throw another model
at you or another module at you here in
just a second we can't go into too much
detail
but it deals specifically working with
words and text
and what they call tokenizing those
words so
let's take this code and let's uh skip
on over to our jupiter notebook
and walk through it and here we are in
our jupiter notebook let's paste that in
there
and i can run this code right off the
bat it's not actually going to display
anything yet
but it has a lot going on in here so the
top we have the print module from the
earlier one
i didn't know why that was in there so
we're going to start by importing our
necessary packages
and from the sklearn features extraction
dot text we're going to import tf idf
vectorizer i told you we're going to
throw a module at you
we can't go too much into the math
behind this or how it works you can look
it up
the notation for the math is usually
tf.idf
and that's just a way of weighing the
words and it weighs the words based on
how many times they're used in a
document how many times
or how many documents are used in and
it's a well-used formula it's been
around for a while
it's a little confusing to put this in
here uh but let's
let her know that it just goes in there
and waits the different words in the
document for us
that way we don't have to wait if you
put a weight on it if you remember i was
talking about that up here earlier if
these are all
emails they probably all have the word
from in them from probably has a very
low weight it has very little value in
telling you what this document's about
same with words like in an article in
articles
in cost of on maybe cost might or
were words like criminal weapons
destruction
these might have a heavier weight
because they describe a little bit more
what the article is doing
well how do you figure out all those
weights in the different articles
that's what this module does that's what
the tf idf vectorizer is going to do for
us
and then we're going to import our
sklearn.naive bayes
and that's our multinomial nb
multinomial naive bayes pretty easy to
understand that where that comes from
and then finally we have the skylearn
pipeline
import make pipeline now the make
pipeline is just a cool piece of code
because we're going to take the
information we get from the tf idf
vectorizer
and we're going to pump that into the
multinomial nb
so a pipeline is just a way of
organizing how things flow
it's used commonly you probably already
guessed what it is if you've done any
businesses they talk about the sales
pipeline if you're on a work crew
or project manager you have your
pipeline of information that's going
through or your projects and what has to
be done in what order
that's all this pipeline is we're going
to take the tfid vectorizer and then
we're going to push that into the
multinomial nb now we've designated that
as the variable model we have our
pipeline model
and we're going to take that model and
this is just so elegant this is done in
just a couple lines of code
model.fit and we're going to fit the
data
and first the train data and then the
train
target now the train data has the
different articles in it
you can see the one we were just looking
at and the train dot
target is what category they already
categorized that
that particular article as and what's
happening here
is the train data is going into the tf
id vectorizer
so when you have one of these articles
that goes in there it weights
all the words in there so there's
thousands of words with different
weights on them i remember once running
a model on this and i literally had
2.4 million tokens go into this
so when you're doing like large document
bases you can have a huge number of
different words
it then takes those words gives them a
weight
and then based on that weight based on
the words and the weights
and then puts that into the multinomial
in b
and once we go into our naive bayes we
want to put the train
target in there so the train data that's
been mapped
to the tfid vectorizer is now going
through the multinomial in b
and then we're telling it well these are
the answers these are the answers to the
different documents so this document
that has all these words with these
different weights
from the first part is going to be
whatever category it comes out of maybe
it's the
talk show or the article on religion
miscellaneous
once we fit that model we can then take
labels
and we're going to set that equal to
model.predict
most of the sklearn used the term dot
predict to let us know that we've now
trained the model and now we want to get
some answers and we're going to put our
test data
in there because our test data is the
stuff we held off to the side
we didn't train it on there and we don't
know what's going to come up out of it
and we just want to find out how good
our labels are do they match what they
should be now i've already run this
through
there's no actual output to it to show
this is just setting it all up
this is just training our model creating
the labels so we can see how good it is
and then we move on to the next step to
find out what happened
to do this we're going to go ahead and
create a confusion matrix and a heat map
so the confusion matrix which is
confusing just by its very name
is basically going to ask how confused
is our answer
did it get it correct or did it miss
some things in there
or have some mis labels and then we're
going to put that on a heat map so we'll
have some nice colors to look at to see
how that plots out
let's go ahead and take this code and
see how that take a walk through it and
see what that looks like
so back to our jupiter notebook and put
the code in there and let's go ahead and
run that code take it just a moment and
remember we had the inline that way my
graph
shows up on the inline here and let's
walk through the code and then we'll
look at this
and see what that means so make it a
little bit bigger
there we go no reason not to use the
whole screen too big
so we have here from sklearnmetrics
import confusion matrix
and that's just going to generate a set
of data that says
i the prediction was such the actual
truth was either agreed with it or is
something different
and it's going to add up those numbers
so we can take a look and just see how
well it worked
and we're going to set a variable mat
equal to confusion matrix
we have our test target our test data
that was not part of the training
very important in data science we always
keep our test data separate
otherwise it's not a valid model if we
can't properly test it with new data
and this is the labels we created from
that test data these are the ones that
we predict it's going to be
so we go in and we create our sn heat
map the sns is our seaborn which sits on
top of the
pi plot so we create a sns dot heat map
we take our confusion matrix and it's
going to be
uh mat dot t and do we have other
variables that go into the sns.heat map
we're not going to go into detail what
all the variables mean the annotation
equals true that's what tells it to put
the numbers here so you have the 166 the
one the zero zero zero one
format d and c bar equals false have to
do with the
uh format if you take those out you'll
see that some things disappear
and then the x tick labels and the y
tick labels those are our target names
and you can see right here that's the
alt atheism
comp graphics comp osms windows dot
miscellaneous
and then finally we have our plt dot x
label remember the sns
or the seaborn sits on top of our
matplot library our plt
and so we want to just tell that x label
equals a true is is true the labels are
true
and then the y label is prediction label
so
we say a true this is what it actually
is and the prediction
is what we predicted and let's look at
this graph because that's probably a
little confusing the way i rattled
through it
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go ahead and flip back to
the slides because they have a black
background they put in there that helps
it shine a little bit better so you can
see the graph a little bit
easier so in reading this graph what we
want to look at
is how the color scheme has come out and
you'll see a line
right down the middle diagonally from
upper left to bottom right
what that is is if you look at the
labels we have our predicted label
on the left and our true label on the
right those are the numbers where the
prediction
and the true come together and this is
what we want to see is we want to see
those lit up that's what that heat map
does
as you can see that it did a good job of
finding those data
and you'll notice that there's a couple
of red spots on there where it missed
you know it's a little confused we talk
about talk religion miscellaneous
versus talk politics miscellaneous
social religion christian versus alt
atheism
it mislabeled some of those and those
are very similar topics so you could
understand why it might mislabel them
but overall it did a pretty good job
if we're going to create these models we
want to go ahead and be able to use them
so let's see what that looks like to do
this let's go ahead and create a
definition a function to run
and we're going to call this function
let me just expand that just a notch
here there we go
i like mine in big letters predict
categories we want to predict the
category
we're going to send it s a string and
then
we're sending it train equals train we
have our training model
and then we had our pipeline model
equals model this way we don't have to
resend these variables each time
the definition knows that because i said
train equals train and i put the equal
for model
and then we're going to set the
prediction equal to the model.predict
s so it's going to send whatever string
we send
to it it's going to push that string
through the pipeline the model pipeline
it's going to go through and tokenize it
and put it through the
tf idf convert that into numbers and
weights for all the different documents
and words
and then i'll put that through our naive
bayes and from it
we'll go ahead and get our prediction
we're going to predict what value it is
and so we're going to return train dot
target names predict
of zero and remember that the train dot
target names
that's just categories i could have just
as easily put categories in there
dot predict of zero so we're taking the
prediction which is a number and we're
converting it to an actual category
we're converting it from um i don't know
what the actual numbers are but let's
say zero equals alt atheism
so we're going to convert that zero to
the word or one maybe it equals comp
graphics so we're going to convert
number one into comp graphics that's all
that is
and then we got to go ahead and and then
we need to go ahead and run this
so i load that up and then once i run
that
we can start doing some predictions let
me go ahead and type in predict category
and let's just do predict category jesus
christ
and it comes back and says it's social
religion christian
that's pretty good now note i didn't put
print on this one the nice things about
the jupiter notebook editor and a lot of
inline editors is if you just put the
name
of the variable out as returning the
variable train.target
underscore names it'll automatically
print that for you
in your own id you might have to put in
print let's see where else we can take
this
and maybe you're a space science buff so
how about
sending load to international
space station and if we run that
we get science space or
maybe you're a automobile buff and let's
do
oh they're going to tell me audi is
better than bmw but i'm going to do bmw
is better than an audi so maybe your car
buff
and we run that and you'll see it says
recreational i'm assuming that's what
rec
stands for autos so i did a pretty good
job labeling that one
how about uh if we have something like a
caption running through there
president of india and if we run that
it comes up and says talk politics
miscellaneous
so when we take our definition our
function and we run all these
things through kudos we made it we were
able to correctly classify
text into different groups based on
which category they belong to using the
naive bayes classifier
now we did throw in the pipeline the
tf idf vectorizer we threw in the graphs
those are all things that you don't
necessarily have to know to understand
the naive bayes
setup or classifier but they're
important to know one of the main uses
for the naive bayes is
with the tf idf tokenizer vectorizer
where tokenizes the word and as labels
and we use the pipeline because you need
to
push all that data through and it makes
it really easy and fast you don't have
to know those understand naive bayes but
they certainly help
for understanding the industry and data
science and we can see
our categorizer or naive bayes
classifier
we were able to predict the category
religion space
motorcycles autos politics and properly
classify
all these different things we pushed
into our prediction and our trained
model
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here